[Music] I
'm buying it
[Music]
I guess
[Applause]
I'm working hard to make
this
mayonnaise mayor for
Subaru-kun.  So this time,
I don't mind if you wear it in the public bath
.
I love Subaru's voice Every time I hear one word, I feel my heart warm
I like Subaru's eyes He's
usually sharp but when he tries to be kind  I like that woman who isn't soft I
like Subaru's fingers Even though he's a
boy, he has beautiful fingers, but when I hold him he makes me think he's a boy after all He's
strong and hot water day
I like the way Subaru-kun walks together  When I'm walking next to you, I sometimes
turn around to see if you're following me.
It's been a
few days and I do
n't even notice when I touch my lips My heart hurts so much I love you
Do you like boats? They pick them up and
smear them and basically don't do anything for them, but they
say that demons will laugh with you when you talk about future prospects,
especially when you talk about next year.
[Music]
That smiling face is dissatisfied I
'll tell Emilia-sama
.  Music]
[music]
me
et al
[music]
[applause]
Hah
ah ah ah
balker is good
don't know don't die don't know don't know ah
if Subaru-kun hates himself
I wanted you to know that there are so many good things about m
.
Mr. Rem, maybe you have a bad drinking habit
, please don't be stupid 3 Subaru-kun, Subaru, don't call me Subaru three times more than
usual.
I
'm sorry, but it's because of you, Zumaru-kun, that it
surpasses the crowd of black rattle rattles
.
But
i ah ah
But Remu-chan is sulking, so I won't call it love at first sight
.
I don't know
how much m was saved that morning in that moment,
woman wasted
Even if that happens, even if no one in the world believes in Subaru-kun, and Pal-kun himself can't believe in himself, I still believe in
him.
pon
[music]
Thank you for your training, Subaru Ward
.
Even if I wasn't ordered to do so, I still had a little bit left
[Music] Because
m wants to do it.
[Music]
Why don't you go out tomorrow?
Khan on the 3rd, you're not going anywhere, are you?
[Music]
I don't like not being involved in Miria's affairs
Subaru or
something, I'm only useful when something happens
So I want to be by Emilia's side at important times From
now on m is urgent  I'm going to start developing a new dish using a ring with an idea
Mana requires a lot of concentration, so
there's a high chance that I won't notice if
someone sneaks out of the room.
After all,
you might get scolded at first,
but take your time, go to town properly,
and if you put your feelings into words, people
will buy you a little bit,
Subaru-kun is just  Emilia is
useless without me.  No matter how hard I tried, I
couldn't save anyone But there's
Rem, who was made by Subaru-kun, is here now
An empty back seat that didn't do anything There's an
m who doesn't listen to
Subaru-kun's words  I want to hear what it is
No one
expects me No one believes me
I can't forgive myself for being like that Let's
start from here Just
like Subaru-kun moved the stopped time of no o m Let's move the time that Subaru-
kun thought was stopped
Let's start from
here  ]
1 from
[music]
nan
[music
] If it's hard to walk, 6 will support
you Open your luggage and support each other Haruko
That's what you said that morning
Please show me your cool side
Subaru Ku